pied est salée bolchaïa tu sais que je
t'adore je t'adore et pavie et sur baby
schumi est arrivé jeudi matin à roubaix
c'est une d'arcade euros fait je vous
dis je suis comme un ouf
tu sais que je te dis pauvre héros je te
kiffe et autres noms on peut le dire et
on n'a pas eu une année facile un à
temps c'était une année difficile pour
tout le monde
cheryl et a vu tout le monde a eu l'aîné
des galères voilà et nous on essaie
l'arn etc on avoue on a voulu rester là
on dirait qu'on a essayé de ne pas
arrêter l'émission
voilà donc on est on est on est allé on
est assez content voilà c'est qu'il ya
juste un truc je te trouve un peu plus
beaux gosses que moi baba est bradée bon
bah alors des pratiques c'est quoi cette
dinguerie avec gad elmaleh qui adapte
après la grande marque à la grande
rigolade
ce soir c'est la grogne à riad et mais
s'est dit notant fils qui écrit les
titres de télévision droit c'est vrai
que l'été des émissions sur l'axé c'est
pas ouf
mais ce soir voilà un cc partie de gad
qui est un de mes meilleurs amis si ce
n'est mon meilleur ami voilà qui qui m'a
dit voilà j'ai envie qu'on se fasse un
délire parce que les gens ils sont dans
lara sera en ce moment vient où on fait
un truc tous les deux où l'on rigole on
se met tous les deux on invite des potes
et on rigole et on charrie pendant
pendant deux heures et on a eu l'idée de
la grosse chariatte ce sera ce soir
c'est une émission vraiment je vous le
dis il ya voilà sa part en cacahuète
total il ya un casting de fou et c'était
juste un kiff que pour voulez vous faire
pour vraiment pour vous changer les
idées avant voilà avant noël avant qu'on
avant que l'on prenne voilà quinze jours
de vacances mais c'est vrai voilà
c'était un certain qu'ils feront voulez
vous faire
ouais alors et baba et 10 mois les yeux
dans les yeux c'était quoi ton aussi
c'était quoi cette race track nous
aimions début d'année balances ton poste
à 17 heures qui dure 20 minutes tp qui
dorment à minutes après on va prendre ou
à laisser et vas-y que je te remets btp
a vanté pmp ouvert à tout juste dix ans
j'ai mal à la tête
frérot alors qu'est ce que tu as voulu
nous faire encore là alors c'est ça le
gars à côté au téléspectateur gt gt
tranquillement en vacances et j'ai eu
gérald brice viret le grand patron des
antennes et julie tu vois il faut étonné
cette année
il faut trois mares tu vois ça y est on
est en train de s'embourgeoiser il faut
trois marques il faut mettre les trois
marques à la suite il faut que je
démarre plutôt faut que je fasse btp en
direct après je fais tes pmp et après je
fais à prendre les cff et tous les soirs
chez un débat une émission de
divertissement et un jeu jamais personne
ne l'a fait en direct en plus donc il
faut y aller il faut le faire et gérald
m'a dit vas-y mon chéri on y va je le
sens bien aussi et c'est vrai que on a
déboussolé les gens parce que c'est vrai
qu'à prendre ou à laisser
il ya plein de gens plus qu'il pouvait
pas le voir parce que les enfants le
regarde beaucoup et on se terminer à
21h20 et c'est vrai que c'était trop
tard
après après voilà apprendre à tour mis
dans l'ordre très vite et c'est vrai que
même moi aujourd'hui
j'avais oublié qu on faisait ça à la
rentrée il y avait btp c'est vrai à
17h30 et btp voilà on l'a remis à sa
place
voilà vous c'est vrai que même moi
j'avais oublié mais voilà c'est chaque
année chez une petite dinguerie en début
d'émission en début d'année voilà
ou bien c'est dans touche pas à mon
poste j'ai essayé de faire un truc mais
vous le savez et les gens le savent tous
ceux qui me suivent depuis des années
chaque année en septembre il dit façon
il va faire un truc mais il faut que ça
dure jamais très longtemps et que deux
semaines après on vient au classique
voilà un os et aux éau base au total
auraient alors bon chez volailles pour
toi c'est noël avant l'heure
ah parce que depuis trois semaines tpp
ça cartonne à et à poils fait ça fait
des records a alors dit moi et c'est
quoi ton secret il écoute j'ai dit au
football
coup de bol non franchement un coup de
bol banon mais en fait on est juste
revenu à ce qu'on savait faire voilà
c'est vrai que tpm p l'équipe elle est
top en ce moment il ya eu il ya eu du
renouveau dans l'équipe
les anciens qui sont là ils sont
toujours aussi bon comme mise à ma
chérie qui est formidable
voilà les nouvelles recrues elles sont
top et c'est vrai quoi on apprend des
choses on est revenue aux médias on est
revenu à ce que les gens aiment c'est à
dire les médias ça déconne beaucoup et
surtout il ya une très très bonne
ambiance c'est à dire qui a pas
d'animosité entre les chroniques entre
mois entre ont fait que déconner et je
crois que ça les gens le ressentent
qu'on est vraiment une famille qu'on a
envie de rigoler et qu'on vient ici
juste pour les détendre pendant pendant
deux heures
et voilà un nom qui fait ensemble je
crois que c'est le cas de tout le monde
et je crois que tous les gens qui sont
là ils sont envie de venir
voilà nicolas pernikoff voilà qui est là
et qui vient d'arriver je sais que tous
les soirs que l'euro a été bon
vous n'avez rien fait mais c'est souvent
comme ça sur les dernières c'est souvent
comme ça sur les dernières mais en tout
cas je sais que vous êtes toujours très
heureux d'être là et je le son et on est
là voilà et puis j'ai je vous dis
reviens j'ai voilà j'ai repris un peu
les les un peu les stand up de début les
vad
voilà on est plus accroché au conducteur
on peut tout péter comme avant et ses
riffs on a retrouvé le tpm paix voilà
voilà que les gens aiment et voilà on
est on se dit il va se passer quelque
chose à chaque fois on en direct et on
sait pas ce qui va se passer
donc on est très heureux en tout cas
alors eh bah et bombes à eau des autres
nous là bas on va passer autre question
qui tue alors ok tu maintenant ben ouais
ouais alors quoi
d'abord est-ce que c'est vrai que la
saison prochaine tu seras plus sur ces 8
et ils 4 sur mesure positive une réponse
de faïal à jean-michel bien les féroé
frérot basis te plaît mettez alors
mettez boulette sur la table alors alors
je sais pas d'où tu tiens cette info
mais il se dit que je serai plus sur ces
8 l'année prochaine
ce qui est sûr et certain c'est que quoi
qu'il arrive je serai dans le groupe
canal l'année prochaine quoiqu'il arrive
que je suis encore trois ans encore en
contrat avec le groupe canal+
donc quoi qu'il arrive je serai dans le
groupe canal+ l'année prochaine et voilà
normalement sur ces 8 à priori mais
voilà non meilleur en tout cas je serai
dans le groupe canal encore pour trois
ans ce qui est sûr et certain donc voila
tu va m'avoir sur le dos encore trois
ans louis nicollin normalement bah oui
c'est incroyable
normalement tout peut arriver ça sur ses
imitations % c'est sûr point barre tout
peut arriver pourquoi vous dites le
groupe canal est passé vite
tout peut arriver je peux remonter 5 km
quoi ont pris une montée en puissance
hors antenne
c'est à dire où ça va
dirigeant en poste à responsabilité je
serai encore à l'antenne pour trois ans
ça c'est sûr et certain il ya d'autres
déjà je me régale avec les
téléspectateurs avec vous aussi
et voilà mais on sait voilà où en écosse
à la contrebande access d'accord c'est
sûr on a fait ce pas sur ces 8 mais vous
n'êtes pas si simpliste oralement ce
sera sur ses mythes mais on sait jarry
mans mais on sait jamais en tout cas je
serai dans group canada
voilà c'est sûr c'est que tu étais en
train dans merde et est battu c'est
contador bolletieri bon alors dis-moi
par la vérité la vérité et sur ma vie là
là là ça reste entre nous est-ce qu'avec
le recul tu regrette d'avoir fait
l'émission ce soir chez bar ce soir
shebab franchement je regrette pas du
tout mais vraiment je regrette pas du
tout parce que je voulais absolument pas
être en plateau à l'époque parce que
c'était une autre époque où les gens
avaient très très très peur de cette
maladie isabelle au sort rappelle
guillaume aussi et c'est vrai que je
voulais pas voilà prendre le risque pour
les équipes etc
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que j'ai dit si
un confinement on sera en plateau alors
c'est pas con à montbron moins peur on
fait plus attention mais on est moins on
est moins angoissée mais ils n'ont rien
par par par l'aco ville à l'époque on
savait pas trop ce que c'était moi
j'avais c'est vrai que j'avais très peur
voilà de contaminer des gens et je me
suis dit vaut mieux que je reste voilà
chez moi à faire l'émission quand même à
rester en contact avec le public
après c'est vrai qu'il ya plein de gens
qui nous ont tapé dessus et pour moi je
trouve ça ça a été vraiment je vous dis
ça a été pour moi j'ai pas compris
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de journalistes
médias qui nous ont tapé dessus sur ce
soir chez ba ba alors qu'on n'avait pas
de vraiment d'objectif d'audience 11 et
600 700 mille téléspectateurs ce qui
était déjà joué je trouve énorme pour
une émission à la maison avec une caméra
sur un ordinateur
voilà et dans un décor de salon et c'est
vrai qu'il ya plein de journalistes qui
ont trouvé ce prétexte là pour me taper
dessus pour dire ana c'est fini hanouna
c'est terminé il a effet 600 mille sept
cent mille téléspectateurs
d'ailleurs je m'en venais d'en parler
avec vous sinon pensez vous l'avez senti
ça moi ça va bien ça va peiner plus par
rapport aux journalistes qui ont l'air
malin plaisir tous les soirs à dire on a
600 milles ou 700 spectateurs alors
qu'ils n'avaient aucun challenge
d'audience près une émission à la main
non je vous le dis pour nous on
s'attendait pas à plus et c'était une
émission bien sûr qu'ils écoutaient je
vous dis pour la chaîne pour pas cherché
à la rue voilà on a concédé voilà donc
c'est une émission
voilà juste ton l'apu quirky qui qui
remboursait les coups voilà de
l'émission mais qui était très très
prochainement on peut dire ce qu'on veut
mais c'était quand même un ovni
télévisuel c'est la première fois que
j'irai un acquéreur t d qu'ils aient une
quotidienne chez lui même nous en
coulisse oiseaux dans la broye heures
c'était incroyable avec des séquences y
était quand même très drôle et même eu
en coulisses on a appris à faire de la
télé différemment on était tous chez
nous on était sur nos ordis portables
je veux dire que moi je prends en
imposer dans pas mal de boîte de prod
différentes c'est incroyable de se
rendre compte qu'on peut faire de la
télé sur un petit ordinateur de primes
pour nous c'était hyper enrichissant
non mais c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des
signes à eric kim applaudi mon chéri
d'un chauffeur de même chez moi ils
chauffer la salle ya des personnes non
mais c'est vraiment une expérience
incroyable je pense qu'on s'en
souviendra en tout cas moi je vous dis
j'étais j'ai trouvé ça vraiment eu mal
venu de la part de certains journalistes
commentaient tous les soirs et tous les
matins les scores d'audience ce qui
était peut-être jusqu'à par la forme
mais sur le contenu il y avait les mêmes
reportages les mêmes débats certains la
maison mais le contenu éditorial ne
changeait pas bien parce qu'on vite et
par tous heureusement qui a vu cette
émission abandonné parce qu'il se
passait plus rien à la télé c'était la
seule émission en direct il y avait un
deuil avait pas d'objectif d'audience
pas d'usiné s'était accompagnée des gens
exactement il y avait pas mal de gens
comme la solitude qui découvrait un une
pandémie on n'avait jamais mais ça se
verrait les rations n'a jamais été
mentionné walthéry pour était dans une
angoisse terrible ça a permis
d'accompagner les gens au quotidien je
veux dire c'était ridicule en est pas là
et après de moi j'ai trouvé que c'est
très audacieux et vous avez fait en
sorte de garder le lien avec les gens et
malgré une pandémie mondiale
et ben hanouna lui il continue d'être à
la télé et j'ai trouvé ça justement très
très fort et très très classe quoi mais
je vais vous dire moi j'étais j'étais
vraiment peiné tous les matins de voir
au lieu de dire 'voilà de ne pas parler
va nous parler des audiences je voyais
tous les jours des articles de
journalistes riz qui disait à les
assumer et me hanoune a raté son
confinement mais est ce qu'on peut
parler d' arrêter son confident a dit
que c'est donc c'est vraiment déplacé
surtout ça je le referais on sait tous
l'émission était extrêmement compliqué à
faire ah bien sûr quelque chose de
simple pour toutes les équipes
il y avait des mesures barrières à
respecter les personnes se voyaient tout
seul vous essayez on l'a vu
un moment il y avait des petits bugs et
les petits bugs antennes et petits
problèmes
donc je vois pas ce qui est peut être
critiquée mais bravo aux équipes à
distance sa mère ou moi je me souviens
parce que pour le coup c'est mon secteur
de patrie médias qui mélangeait
absolument tous les chiffres qui
comparer des choses qui étaient
absolument pas comparable en disant à
telle période l'année dernière et zettel
l'audience et ouvriers regarder rien
c'est s était pas c'était vraiment
malveillants excaver ce moment c'était
c'était malvenu et malveillant je suis
assez d'accord mais dire a dit et d'un
point de vue totalement égoïste c'est
vrai que c'était bien aussi de faire
cette émission pour nous c'est à dire
que nous on ne voyait plus du jour grâce
à cet arrêté
moi j'aimais bien que les zooms parce
que ça on était en zoom avant que
l'émission de commence ça nous
permettait de parler entre nous on
demandé à jean me abadie alors qu est ce
que tu fais et toi voilà et ça crée
aussi un lien par rapport à la famille
tmp ajouté me rinck mandat courait ce
que face à ses côtés vous ai dit
faudrait peut-être qu'on revienne en
plateau un peu plus tôt non non non non
je voulais vraiment terminer la saison
voilà chez moi et qu on les découvre des
conflits que j'ai dit à la chaîne faut
proposer autre chose un jeu voilà pour
parvenir en plateau tout de suite avec
des pmp
il faut revenir avec un jeu on a lancé à
prendre et s'excuser
voilà c'est tout mais je me suis
tellement will champion dit souvent que
les émissions de télé font tout pour
l'ambiance là quoi qu'on en dise vous
avez privilégié la sécurité la santé des
équipes votre santé à vous aussi
en faisant cette émission et puis donc
moi j'ai trouvé ça très fort et vous est
ce qu'elle est à l'époque faut se
remettre dans la situation en mars on
pensait que c'était ebola legault vie
des blancs j'ai cherché on avait peur de
se parler donc c'est vrai que faire une
émission en plateau à l'époque mais on
se demandait si elle a encore avoir des
chaînes de télé on savait même pas si
les chaînes info elle existe et la
panique totale donc dans l'époque
c'était normal à l'époque de deux heures
cette émission confiné rabat à d'autres
questions mon chéri dis-moi dis-moi bas
je vois que ton équipe se renouvelle
beaucoup mais dis moi on a roulé entre
nous c'est qui la personne qui te manque
le plus la personne qui manque le plus
ouais je les ai déjà dit ici je jouais
déjà 10 1 s'est passé c'est julien
courbet qui participa vraiment julien
courbet qui était vraiment un camarade
de jeu avec moi au vraiment je m'éclate
et avec lui on se comprenait ont rigolé
tous les deux il y en a plein qui
manquent
enora voilà jean luc thierry tout ça
mais c'est vrai que le lait qui me
manque le plus c'est quand même
jean lui julien courbet et jean-luc
williams et julien courbet voilà qui me
manque énormément parce que j'adorais
être avec lui et saint voy la mecque a
toujours qui est toujours de bonne
humeur il le sait que là
ce sera toujours ouverte pour lui dans
le groupe canal plus et essayer sur ces
mythes et alors pas là je vais être
sérieux tu sais qu'on vit une période
compliquée en ce moment à ronronner
touche tous ces deux touches touchés de
près ou de loin par parole la maladie tu
sais que notre papa a été touché par
l'aco vide
malheureusement comment tu l'as vécu toi
alors ben moi c'était pendant le
confinement en plus donc c'est vrai que
c'était c'est assez compliqué et c'est
vrai que l'on voit la gt gt entre les
missions et essayer de m'occuper du à
distance que je pouvais pas aller le
voir
il est il a passé lui il a passé quatre
mois à l'hôpital c'est vrai qu'il s'en
est sorti miraculeusement parce qu'ils
la voient là et aujourd'hui je suis très
heureux je vois là mais chaque jour
c'est vrai que je vis dans l'angoissé de
me dire est-ce qu'il va rights qui va le
rattraper
est-ce qu'il va retourner à l'hôpital ça
reste un traumatisme mais c'est vrai que
voilà j'ai je me suis dit à un moment ça
va être compliqué et on cyril mon frérot
tu sais que tout le monde adore 1 je te
le dis et je le répète tous les jours tu
testes pleine séquence des nouveaux
délires ça change tout le temps là
aujourd'hui sartec c'est moi mais est ce
que tu crois que je dois revenir après
les vacances et je vous le dis après les
vacances on a décidé avec les équipes et
ça c'est vraiment un scoop de faire
venir une marionnette par rapport à une
actu tous les jours une marionnette des
guignols
voilà et de refaire venir par exemple si
on parle pas d'eux des nrj music awards
on aura nikos voilà ciré et voilà et
tous les jours on aura une marionnette
pour une séquence et à la rentrée et
sincèrement vu les tests qu'on a fait je
pense que c'est vraiment une séquence
qui va perdurer parce qu'elle va
s'intégrer en fait à l'équipe et elle
donnera son avis ce sera un peu comme un
invité
voilà si on débrief incroyable talent en
aura un karine le marchand qui sera la
voix la wii ou ferait revenir des
anciens aussi comme philippe gildas ou
l'hexagone alors peut-être géniale idée
je pense que pépé
l'idée est joueurs merci d'ailleurs les
deux marionnettistes qui sont là et sont
venus ce soir qu'elle n'avait rien que
pour aussi les revoir et qu'il faut au
travail voilà et qui re phase voilà ce
qu'ils savent faire
on aura tous les soirs une marionnette
donc touche pas à mon poste à partir de
la rentrée est vraiment merci merci
d'avoir été là parce que c'est un
travail de chiens et en plus voilà
normalement ils font leurs trucs et dont
et avec hanouna ils savent pas qu'elles
aient tour de table tout ça donc il va
falloir qu'on en parle parce que c'est
vrai que ce moment merci merci merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
exactement voilà et merci et regardez
vous fait très peur comme ça
merci à tous merci c'est la première
fois qu'on voit ça je crois et bah bravo
et merci merci
[Applaudissements]